[Music]
okay speaking of jobs
and speaking of this being the best job
we've ever had i we're going to look at
10 careers
that people believe are traps
traps traps and trash oh you know what i
think is a trap um school that i mean
not school but yeah uh professional
careers because in school they tell you
like oh be you know you want to aim
higher be a lawyer whatever right and
like people don't really tell you like
how soul sucking it is and dude traps
just to be clear like like when you show
up for this job it has a dick
it has a penis
that's what you're talking about oh
that's what i meant just breaking the
fourth wall steering to the camera
that's what it says in article no it's
like you got the job now suck
and it's like what oh wait i wasn't
expecting so are you talking sign up for
this [ __ ] are they referring are they
referring to things like for example uh
you you [ __ ] going to like law school
and the next thing you know you're like
six years in you owe like three hundred
thousand dollars you actually [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ] that's what i mean by
professional jobs
since um
[Laughter]
so since i figured that you know most of
us uh almost everybody that comes
through this show
usually has like an unorthodox
profession of some sort i think it'd be
interesting to look at the ones that um
are orthodox or orthodox but are also
i kind of the people that end up in
these careers feel so demystified and
they go wow it was not what the school
said it would be it was not with the
parents that's why you got an intern you
son of a [ __ ] number 10 president you
make your first job oh yeah
oh yeah yeah for sure they're like i
thought i was gonna [ __ ] eat a lot of
kids
number 10 is number 10. and i think if
we got people watching that are kind of
in that transitionary period where they
still don't know where they want to end
up uh this will be a little bit of a
good info for you i blame the people
with imaginations it's like you thought
that yeah i'm like dude you thought
being with they're actually the
innovators but
you thought you were gonna be a doctor
like on house and then you show up and
it's nothing like it and it has a penis
yeah let's not let's not forget that
number 10. all right let's go [ __ ]
let's go buzzfeed damn it
these are collected from people on
reddit that are actually in these
careers the most trusted news source
yeah yep so it's very it's like
crowdfunded information all right uh
real estate agents yeah that kind of
makes sense but at the same time isn't
that one of those things where it's like
you can get your license and do it and
then like not do it and it's nothing
happens is it one of those things too
it's like it's you get out of it what
you put into it yeah absolutely with
anything
that's that one thing
like anything
right like put effort into something
it's a little bit of a scam but no but
no but like you know you know what i
mean you get a degree and you go sit at
a [ __ ] desk and you barely even work
all day and you just [ __ ] chill chill
out and then you're like i don't know
why you don't have clients like that
yeah yeah so
it has an extremely high failure rate uh
there's more homes for sale in the us
than there are um actually there's more
real estate agents than our homes for
sale that's [ __ ] hilarious actually
and uh going to school for that doesn't
teach you how to be a good realtor it
just teaches you how to not get sued
yeah it's just teaching the rules oh
okay so
other than that it's mainly kind of like
personal training yeah honestly
it's very similar all the personal
trainers that like a lot of personal
trainers i used to work with have uh
quit personal training to be real estate
agents and like i think there's a lot of
parallels between the same thing happens
to like cheerleaders in the nba they
real estate agents they become personal
trainers well cheerleaders make really
great uh realtors in my opinion because
they can talk sports which is like
that's that's a huge ass level that's a
fact
dude hot real estate ladies also do
really well i feel like if you're good
with people a sales position is great
just in all industries because in
reality real estate is just purely sales
right like that's it if you're
i think there's some network in there as
well i think that's
i think that's in the bubble of sales
right it's like connecting with people
and if you don't have that then your
ceiling of growth is a lot lower it's
like what steve said though it's like
one of those things where if you just go
to it the way that you would go to
school and go oh at the end of this
school year i'm gonna be good at it it's
like not at all you gotta learn the
ropes of the trade you know dude my
neighbor is a [ __ ] real estate agent
like my next good writer is well i don't
know because i mean that's always
interesting isn't it because i nikki's
dad's a cpa but i think he's actually
probably dog [ __ ] at it only because
only because
i've never heard anyone say a good thing
about him
only because and he's asked around
he's taking a pull down
[Laughter]
no when your dad is a thing right it's
it's always something that when your
dad's thinking you always you always
have to wonder in the back of your head
is he a good one though because you
don't necessarily know yeah oh but yeah
he's not getting fired it's got to be
pretty decent but my next door
neighborhood
every time that we go to any of our
neighbors houses i actually put him to
the test i'm like sell me this [ __ ]
house and
he does try to do it he sells his own
house to you no he sells whatever house
we're in to me he tries to he's just
moving to different houses and i think
he's pretty [ __ ] good at it actually
because he's like you need a house i'm
like i do he's like boom you're good
hey you looking for alex hey look no
more
hey you're inside look no further than
boom it's done here's one that that uh i
think we totally saw coming
3d cg artists really it's a trap yeah
it's a trap why what's a trap about it
it has a dick sucking
i'm gonna be a computer graphics guy and
then you get the first deal zip yeah
oh jeez
[Laughter]
steve green was right
he tried to warn me i sat down at the
computer all of a sudden the [ __ ]
dick came out of nowhere i thought it
was a bit it's a trap oh my god i just
wanted to make video games
not the gulp
not the swallow i'm getting my cheek
[ __ ]
good lord this wasn't a part of the job
description i didn't know i thought it
was software not hard i hope this is
helping some of you pick a career yeah
it's all trapped into the porn industry
that's gonna be in my trap yeah so it's
not because of like pop culture it's
because of the schools themselves trying
to tell people like those trade schools
exactly yeah [ __ ] those film schools
it's so hot in here
you guys don't remember seeing that on
tv where they're like don't you want to
work in video games and then they would
show you like all these things and like
it only takes eight months and now you
can work making games and like they make
it all like cool sounding but i didn't
think i'd have a future and then i got
into itt tech
it's a trap i don't think it was this
game because those guys had really nice
colored shirts on
and they all had like cg like they have
b-roll their family and then once they
got caught it was like hey
i went to devry yeah you just move on
the newest on the block is grand canyon
university that's the new everybody who
goes into that field you know like you
have dreams of animating at disney or
something but what happened was the
market got oversaturated with low
quality portfolios and no chance to ever
get into a major studio because you have
to be so [ __ ] good yeah so it's all
skill based huh that's what it sounds
like for all of us so what's the next
one veterinarian veteran i've heard that
too my sister's what's a scam about that
the
the same amount of debt as if you were
an md
with a fraction of the salary
you do it so you can have a stethoscope
and [ __ ] hear the heartbeat of a dog
man my sister my sister would honestly
make no money
in this profession
because veterinarian [ __ ] is hard as
[ __ ] right yeah yeah she would make
almost no because she pays so much like
for she pays two mortgages she has a
mortgage and then she also pays for her
schooling yeah it did but she she would
make zero money in this entire game if
she wasn't so [ __ ] hot good lord
jesus this is really really she's able
to sell she's able to sell a lot of
people
leverage yeah
if she's a beautiful doctor i'd always
send my dogs there like your dog needs
surgery they're like i just want to get
shampooed they're like we need to rush
this thing to surgery yeah we had some
x-rays yeah that would be four thousand
dollars each and then
and then she leans over to her attack
and she's like cha-ching
that's stupid sounds like a good crowd
his sister is hot though she's very hot
did you want to make sure you knew that
yeah can i say a photo i'll show you
yeah i'll show you a picture it's more
of a feeling
it's more of a feeling it's more of a
feeling
i didn't catch
them it's a trap yeah
it's not a physical line uh beekeeping
oh no way i always wanted to get
beehives really that's the trap you're
falling for oh it got so trendy to do
that just wanted to
that's the most joe thing i've ever
heard
dude you know i wanna
well i got i i i i have access to a farm
now i could put i could keep bees but
it's just four hours away it's a trap
dude
tell me tell me why uh yeah because it
got so trendy to do that yet let's say
um if you spend like 400 bucks on the
equipment you could probably get honey
for the rest of like yeah that amount of
honey and that same amount of money
you'll never make that much like say
honey said monomoney so the so the cost
of the equipment costs more than what
you can make out of the honey well it
doesn't it just doesn't make sense but
that's not thinking next level [ __ ]
because if you if you cover your your
honeycomb with mustard it becomes honey
mustard now you can sell that to fast
food you market you're selling your
target you're on to something here dude
you want to diversify or do you want to
be a loser like which one is it you're
really
you you gotta think outside the box
you're not thinking next level you're
just trying to you're thinking about
something everyone in the 1800s did
you're not thinking about honey mustard
which is now yeah think about something
old which is honey yeah all the all the
current beekeepers they're the pga steve
green over here he's live golf baby i'm
live golf dude i'm telling you he's he's
with the saudis just kiss right here i'm
[ __ ] extracting
buckets and buckets of honey mustard out
of my [ __ ] beethoven
where did you get the mustard what was
that
that response you have to grow mustard
too bro look you just [ __ ]
good thing about honey mustard it's a
two to one honey to mustard ratio
so he he just needs all the honey and
that must be that's right right i don't
know
do i go i go to costco i get the big
yellow one and then i just dump that
[ __ ] thing in my beard
here's something here's something i
didn't really think was a trap because i
don't even remember this sounding like
you wanted to do it but librarian
apparently what's the trouble about that
you get unlimited books you need a
master's to be a librarian my mommy's
going through the master's program hey
my homies going through the master's
program and she makes six figures as a
master's librarian yeah but where does
she work at the smithsonian or some [ __ ]
those guys are so subsidized by
government money are you kidding me
she
she makes six figures as uh no [ __ ]
way
what's a master librarian versus a
librarian like a student librarian he
has a master's degree you gotta get a
master's in library science so you just
have to know how to [ __ ] alphabetize
and be like well yeah that's what that's
what it's saying here is that there's so
many people that work as librarians that
didn't get a master's anyway and they
just [ __ ] got the job so so what's
the [ __ ] point so why are we
youtubers this is [ __ ]
whack
let's go have to alphabetize the books
because
[Laughter]
shut the [ __ ] up
that's so easy give me those books i got
to absolutely the biggest gig i've ever
heard about [ __ ] waking up students
and telling them you can't sleep here
hey you can't skateboard here get the
[ __ ] out of here
you're just a [ __ ] like the meanest
library but you know what those oh look
who it is finally with the tom sawyer
you know how late this is
why don't you just keep it librarians
live forever though so for you to
actually get your job
you got to wait till you're 55 after you
graduate
yeah once again never die sorcerer
supreme right away
they have a 70-year [ __ ] job security
what about this emt paramedic oh low-key
that's [ __ ] up
i took i took an emt class
halfway through i realized i thought
like the base pay is like 11
and you have to like help dying people
and i was like nah bro i'm out what's
your rate for helping a dying person 12
well for that amount of training i
realized as we watched a video of uh a
bomb going off and people are getting
blown up and then right after i saw that
i was like i can't do this [ __ ] job
and i left that's the training video
yeah that was like the first thing to
show you like mass murder and it's like
hey can you stomach this that's kind of
good training i guess well hey it weeded
me out and i was very glad i didn't do
emt training thank you for your service
you said no one i liked the zip thing
that was good
i showed up for emt they
zip
all right we got time for one more so
we're just gonna pick teacher oh [ __ ]
teacher really mm-hmm
is it also a trap what kind of teacher
that makes sense any kind
you mean like a school teacher yeah i
mean they've been saying for like
decades now the teachers are underpaid
under valued really long hours you don't
really stop doing it did teachers know
about this librarian's camera
just it's adjacent it's right there
right there it's a [ __ ] you park in
the same place that shouldn't be on the
left but that's the weird uh circle
about give us a couple more really quick
okay really want some lightning round
yeah
physical therapy oh
i heard that too
really i've heard that too because it's
uh on top of requiring a four year
undergrad it's a doctorate program the
doctor program is pretty hard no you
used to be a bachelor yeah you could be
a pt with uh without a doctor you can
get your your like your master's in it
right when you get your master's then
you're actual pt but pta is an assistant
the tuition to pay ratio in terms of how
long you're gonna be in that debt so
what like before it used to be bachelors
are they just grandfathered into the
system
because all the pts that are working
previously
yeah i think there's certain things you
can do as a doctor of pt and then
there's certain things you can do as
just a regular pc like if you're a pt
you can work at a clinic but if you're a
doctor pt you can open the clinic yeah
oh well
thank god i'm not one of those
oh well
zip
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you